oh this dude too was just such a such a
letdown i used to look up to ksi because
like i said he did he used to do um
music fighting he has multiple
businesses he does a lot of cool stuff
and that's ultimately what i want for my
brains now he's celebrating the
censorship yeah okay and he used to be
funny too anyone's celebrating
censorship thumbs down hold on
because
you do say some
quality things
[Music]
can you do your replace
you're getting raped today
[Music]
what would you do if you were invisible
oh you're
wow people do some weird [ __ ]
this guy did not get banned for
being mean to women no okay interesting
[Music]
punch me so i can get my satisfaction
yeah i see he this gives me like the
heebie-jeebies still don't bet him just
entertainment
you're getting raped today
what
yeah i just
i just want to [ __ ] her i just want to
go to your sister's house
make her a nice dinner and then once
she's full up i want to bend her over
and just [ __ ] her so i found harry's
sister until you're getting raped today
oh well harriet
i guess she's single now huh
you're getting late today
ksi did a q a with casper lee in the
beginning of the video ksi said that he
wanted to [ __ ]
casper lee's sister that's just this is
just inappropriate material but jj
casper lee's sister was upset and she
made a video yesterday talking about
this titled breaking the silence
every time you talk you break the
silence i hit that expression
can you do your rape face
who's a threat to women and this is the
thing this is the thing is the personal
message to you ksi i have no problem
with you i don't [ __ ] know you i
don't want your [ __ ] youtube channel
but when i get banned you want to go
from a fan to just [ __ ] instantly
cowering out to the matrix that makes
you a hypocrite there's nothing more
disgusting in the world but a male
hypocrite ethan's a hypocrite as
disgusting as are you you don't even
stick by your guns you don't even no no
he doesn't stick by his [ __ ] guns he
doesn't even say you know what andrew
was all right he said some funny things
he shouldn't about banned at least jake
paul was mad enough to say stand up for
[ __ ] free speech if you ever fought
jake he would smash your [ __ ] face
he's [ __ ] smoking and if you want to
get smoked twice i'll [ __ ] smoke you
myself you are full of [ __ ] you're a
[ __ ] hypocrite the [ __ ] you've said
in the past is worse than anything i've
ever [ __ ] said and you know it you
will talk about having a boxing match
your [ __ ] three rounds boxing against
some nobody i will take you 12 rounds
and i'll break every bone in your
[ __ ] face and you know it either
before or after jake's done with you
you're a [ __ ] hypocrite as well
[ __ ] dork [ __ ] ksi
ksi just fought those two people this
weekend did i show you that video no i
have no oh my god
respect the ksi for getting in the ring
but he fought two of like the shittiest
boxers that i've literally ever seen in
my life so he his thing was like two
boxers one night and he knocked them
both out but i mean [ __ ] grandma
could have knocked them out i mean like
it was actually unbelievable it was
insane still respect to him i'm having
gone in the ring yet that would be cool
one day no no no i do want to box
somebody one day that'd be so dope i'll
box you kick your ass because all these
people are hypocrites who's the other
guy giving me [ __ ] true jordy saying i'm
a weirdo and i'm [ __ ] i'm from some
rich guy i'm a rich guy from a rich
family oh yeah yeah exactly yeah dad's
money yeah dad's money when when this
world number two came out in a recent
youtube video saying we're right and
that there's no money in chat the world
number two in chess came out and said
yeah these guys are right there's no
money in chess my father played the
tate's father yeah exactly you all talk
about sexual deviancy how about the
screenshots of true geordie begging for
dildos
let's talk about this begging for dildos
up his butt and he insulted girls who
used to work for the business i used to
please could i suck the dildo is it big
and black please put up my bum all you
have to do is google this up google true
jordy google true geordi's screenshots
and then what was it this is the guy
saying i'm dangerous and then what was
it no one said i saw a true majority
clip would you ever fight undertake
i wonder if those are real because i've
seen a lot of fake dms it's pretty easy
to do that stuff who was like who was he
talking to just i don't know i don't
even know who that is just some youtuber
guy who was talking [ __ ] about tate and
got caught with screenshots of that
stuff that's a rough one that's cotton
4k don't put your [ __ ] in writing i know
what are you thinking g what are you
thinking that's just dumb if i ever saw
andrew take i punched him in the face i
[ __ ] dare you to try it
i double i dare you fatty you fat [ __ ] i
dare you to even try
they're going to cry
but i don't want to go running every day
so yeah oh yeah if you ran every day you
wouldn't get your [ __ ] ass handed to
you
[ __ ] you ain't going to do a thing
nobody's rude this is another message
embarrassing
yeah exactly like what the [ __ ] is wrong
i will fight ksi and true jordy in the
same night make that for a youtube
boxing show i will beat both of them i
will beat both of them sorry true jordan
you're going to take some time off
sucking things and go for a little bit
of a run sorry i know you're a very lazy
individual absolutely nothing i have was
given to me you're just jealous that i'm
more successful than you i am
monumentally successful and you just
have a crappy little youtube channel
with a massive bump in the road and the
bump in the road is you getting caught
taking dildos up the ass that is your
fault nobody else is [ __ ] we have no
skeletons in our closet that's why
you're trying to [ __ ]
try and get us banned that's why you're
going to talk [ __ ] about us because we
have no skeletons in our closet the
whole world's eyes are on us and not a
single girl like the girl in the ksi
video crying oh he said this to me doing
reaction videos not a single female has
come forward upset about anything i've
ever said to her i am a [ __ ]
gentleman you are
i don't know it's true it's true you
know you're a [ __ ] lady it's true
dillo off your butt no it's actually a
really good point i'm a gentleman it's a
good voice i'll say this some bags
dressed like this i hold open [ __ ]
doors i was on a date today open the
door to the car open the door to the
restaurant i pay for dinner give her a
rose kiss her on the cheek drop her home
i didn't ask her to put dildos up my
butt the [ __ ] is wrong with you
all right guys if this i don't even know
if we're gonna be able to really have
this up on youtube very long and if this
does get taken down do follow us on
rumble because we will have full
uncensored videos there where we can
react to stuff like this so listen all
i'm gonna say is what's the guy with the
dildo up is where true jordy that's his
gym i mean tate likes hitting girls
everybody's got their thing i
you know i'd rather no well i'm not even
i would definitely not rather have a
dildo in the bun i do not want to insert
a dildo into anyone's bum either but
just saying i guess this is what some
people like clearly he likes that if
he's you know having that whole like put
taken the time to put it in writing oh
this is [ __ ] i hate this is he going
you know the thing is though grow up but
the thing is you know what's crazy the
matrix has tried this so and the in the
height of the media storm against me
after they silenced me about 15 of my
ex-girlfriends were called they were
contacted were contacted by reporters
saying do you have anything bad to say
by andrew do you think about the same
andrew now
if i wasn't a gentleman because these
are all ex-girlfriends they have no
reason to protect me they all called me
andrew these people are out to get you
this is unfair i'd never turn on you you
were so nice to me you're such a good
man not a single woman turned on me ksi
is out here with women talking about how
he makes someone comfortable talk about
rape face i don't have a single woman
who's come forward saying i've done
anything bad in fact only the contrary i
have endless women coming forward saying
i'm a nice man not a single woman has
come forward and said i have hurt them
or have done anything bad to them not a
single one even when they were offered
money to lie about me they still
wouldn't do it whereas ksi's sitting
here with things like this out in the
open he's not canceled true geordi's
clearly a sexual deviant he isn't
cancelled ah like this is where he's
just getting hypocritical because yeah
the guy likes to take dildos in the bung
that's weird but you also like to whack
girls like i think that's weird too he's
got his right he's got his his things
that he enjoys and the other guy's got
his things that he enjoys now the rapey
guy that's a little weird that whole
thing was just gross i think it was like
a while ago and it was it's just a it's
just a really bad joke yeah it's parody
but it's he's also he's also a lot
younger probably well he was a lot
younger i hope he's grown past that and
critches at it excuse me hope he finds
it cringe-worthy now because it is
cringe-worthy
yeah that shit's really cringy he's
saying which we already talked about him
being a racist and a sexist misogynist
he ain't canceled and everyone's gonna
and pretend they canceled me because i'm
assaulting me i don't want a [ __ ] lie
i don't want youtube i think this is
petty i think this whole section is
petty and i and i think they should i
get i get where they're doing it but
they're just showing what they're really
doing is showing the hypocrisy and the
people that are excited that they're
canceled and they're like well the oh
these are the guys celebrating let's
look at what let's look at their past
that's that's i think that's the big
thing i know i again i get the point i
just i really do just think that they're
trying to give them a taste of their
medicine because they're too smart they
know that
yeah i know i get what they're doing
again i think it's petty
[Music]